[Musica]
sto facendo sta giocando supermario e
sto anche vincendo supermario a
occhiobello anch'io voglio giocarci
voglio giocare con luigi aspetta ora il
mio turno sto giocando io adesso lo
giocherei con una stretta devo finire il
turno va bene aspetto aspettato dieci
secondi
questo carelli hotel giocando io con
mario adesso giochi tu dopo con luigi
uffa posso giocare adesso mi styling
credo che stai facendo perdere io voglio
giocare da giocare
e tu tu tu invece ti sei marian mario
maria sensi di nuovo la trasformazione è
sì un bambino perché era diventato un
funghetto andiamo non possa rimanere
così come super mario super maria dovuta
geneva affidano troppo fastidiosi dai
melissa ma sei sicura e nonno fastidio
che non si possono togliere così come no
sono i dati di un videogioco su penso
che funzionerà o svetta paura contadina
3 ok 12
male
i baffi adesso basta
adesso non ce l'hai con i baffi e senza
perché hai voluto ritirare per giocare a
super mario come l'altra volta dobbiamo
solo trovare un sistema per uscire
magari ci sarà una challenge da fare
hai sentito il rumore che proviene dallo
studio di nintendo
se vuoi tornare normale trova tutti gli
ingredienti slime ritroverà per primo
tornerà normale quindi siete l'uno
contro l'altro
quindi dobbiamo giocare uno contro
l'altro questa volta ma come l'uno
contro l'altro quindi chi perde rimarrà
per sempre così beh allora che la
challenge a vista
ok ragazzi luigi e andato di là
cioè vitale cioè luigi va beh io quindi
proverò a cercare gli ingredienti in
studio ma mi raccomando se non avete
ancora lasciato un bel mi piace e
lasciate un mi piace e se questo video
raggiunge i 30 mila mi piace
dovrò anche cercare gli ingredienti
slime nascosti dal funghetto merlino mi
raccomando non devi allearti con vitale
cioè luigi capito
devi allearti con me mario cioè marea
non ti alleare con luigi marino è troppo
preso dal grano chiare il suo giochino
quindi spero che aiuterà me non lui
gestiamo in studio guardiamoci bene
intorno e speriamo di trovare gli
ingredienti prima di luigi vediamo qua
non c'è niente forse qua dentro la
candela una colla e the verde quindi
forse era la colla per luigi ma ora
vediamo un po forse qua dietro nella
pianta guardate la paletta ti amo se c'è
qualcos'altro ha nascosto da qualche
parte dietro no
guardate un'altra paletta era nascosta
benissimo ho già trovato tre cose la
colla verde e due palette una rossa e
una verde quindi immagino che una fosse
per lui si può che sono mia adesso
almeno so che lui non troverà queste
cose prima di bene ora direi dove
possiamo andare a trovare gli altri
ingredienti forse potremo uscire fuori
in giardino
che ne pensate magari il sommo fuori in
giardino ma che succede
merlino e queste una tartaruga luigi mi
ha colpito non c'è più la colla e la
bolletta verde mi ha colpito con questa
ed è scappato via rubato gli ingredienti
1 ora lui in vantaggio su di me marina
dobbiamo fare qualcosa dobbiamo trovarlo
subito è prenderli nuovamente gli
ingredienti è capito ora ho io questa
tartaruga nella posso tirare io in testa
e rubarli in ingredienti cerchiamolo
subito cominciare un foto sono riuscito
a prendere colla e paletta o ultra poco
attento allora parliamoci un po intorno
vediamo se troviamo qualcosa
siamo fuori usciamo a controllare fuori
chiediamo se c'è qualcosa non ne sono
sicuro microsim do un'occhiata un po in
giro ma chi è ritrovo qualche altro
ingrediente qui sono stato abbastanza
fortunato per il momento c'è qualcosa là
fuori
forse e meglio sarà vada a prendere
magari pianeta ma io da un paio di aiuto
aiuto doppia fermo fermo fermo dove è
andato si è nascosto zione fa stavo
quasi per prendere luigi ma sia nascosto
da qualche parte ma già chiesto
lingiardi noi cerchiamo gli ingredienti
qua non so se avete visto prima
mentre luigi si stava guardando intorno
ho trovato la colla ora anche i viola
col non solo luigi che me l'ha rubata
guardate cerali io cosa sei dentro
magari una trappola vediamo ad aprirla
implica mettiamo dentro anche la zona e
prendiamo lo scatolo sono tornate in
studio o ancora la tartaruga perché
luigi è sparito e ho il mio cubo in cui
ho recuperato questi ingredienti
bicarbonato colla e paletta quindi se
non sbaglio vita le sue luigi a la colla
e la paletta ma finché non è il
bicarbonato non potrà fare niente spero
che lui non abbia già trovato la
soluzione per lenti però come facciamo
andiamo alla ricerca della soluzione per
lenti e portiamoci la tartaruga nel caso
che lo incontriamo se non fatta non mi
ha trovato che cos'è quella cosa lì vi
faccio vedere portate c'è una cosa
stranissima di cos'è questa cosa una
banana sembra abbiamo a prenderla bene e
con cui cosa servirà di certo non per
fare lo slime ma probabilmente la potrò
lanciare contro mario o maria o marian
sicuramente ci aiuterà
aspettate
e quello non mi dire sì risoluzione per
letti finalmente che è bello ho già la
colla la spatola la soluzione per lenti
e manca solo il bicarbonato sono troppo
potenti più anche questa banana c'è
qualcuno è lì che vi sta guardando
qualcuno è un po arrabbiato là dietro
chissà mi sta minacciando chi vuole dire
nella tartaruga addosso nonno ho trovato
che cos'è quello di banana è la
soluzione per lenti tanto ora vengo a
prenderla andiamo luigi ha trovato
l'unico ingrediente che mi manca ma
usciamo fuori
egli tirerò la tartaruga in testa anche
se lui era una specie di banana ma non
penso che serva a niente
bravi
io l'ho soluzione per lenti tu no questo
no
gli emiliani si sa mai
nascondiamo qui tira scadiamo qui dove è
lui è venuta un'idea lasceremo la banana
qui così scivolerà
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ragazzi abbiamo tutto essere letti come
paletta dobbiamo spiegarci adesso
bene ora non mi resta che creare lo slam
per tornare dell'anita stories di sempre
sbrighiamoci colle glitterata sono le
tiene per lenti e bicarbonato pochezze
tutto
iniziamo mescolare blues live si sta
creando
manca poco ad es non sai decordi pronto
[Musica]
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
luigi è sì lo so che tu hai tutti gli
ingredienti e stai per vincere però io
non voglio rimanere luigi voglio
ritornare invitanti prima fila si
aggiungo anche la via colla così almeno
vinciamo entrambi beh effettivamente
potremmo anche vincere in due invece di
vincere da soli sia non mi vorrai mica
lasciare qui a vantare funghi e buccia
di banana ma dai
e va bene aggiungere d'accordo
occhiobello grazie grazie
va detto subito online
così verde oro robert rock diventerò mai
vorrei dove era deciso girare aspetta
aspetta lavoro di squadra è quasi pronto
eccolo è un sito verde
eccolo pronto guardo è uscito verde con
i glitter oro che non si ritrasforma
chiamo in noi stessi effettivamente non
lo so come dovrebbe funzionare
non capisco perché non torniamo normali
forse dobbiamo solo tirarlo che bello
abbiamo vinto assieme mi raccomando
adesso ricordiamoci di non litigare mai
più per i videogiochi
si hai perfettamente ragione questa
volta
lasciate un bel mi piace per altri video
venture attiva e noi ora vi lasciamo qua
quattro cartellini su cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite
guardami
[Musica]